Life is fundamentally different from
dead stuff or is it physicist having
shredding a defined life this way,
living things avoid decay
into disorder and equilibrium.
What does this mean? Let's pretend the
chore download folder is the Universe.
It started orderly and got more
and more chaotic over time.
By investing energy,
you can create order and clean it up.
This is what living things do,
but what is life?
Every living thing on this
planet is made of cells.
Basically a cell is a protein based robot.
Too small to feel or experience anything.
It has the properties we
just assigned to life.
It has a wall that separates it from
the surroundings creating order.
It regulates itself and maintains a
constant state is eat stuff to stay alive.
A grows and develops.
It reacts to the environment and it's
subject to evolution and it makes more of
itself, but of all the stuff that
makes up a cell, no part is alive.
Stuff reacts chemically with other stuff.
Forming reactions that start to other
reactions which start other reactions in a
single cell. Every second, several
million chemical reactions take place.
Forming eight complex orchestra.
A cell can build several thousand
types of protein, some very simple,
some complex micro machines.
Imagine driving a car at 100 kilometers
an hour while constantly rebuilding
every single part of it with
stuff you collect from the street.
That is what cells do,
but no part of the cell is alive.
Everything is dead matter moved by
the laws of the universe is life.
The aggregate of all these reaction
processes that are taking place.
Eventually every living thing will die.
The goal of the whole process is to
prevent this by producing new entities,
and by this we mean DNA.
Life is in a way just a lot of stuff
that carries genetic information around.
Every living thing is subject to evolution
and the DNA that develops the best
living thing around it
will stay in the game,
so his DNA life.
Then if you take DNA out of its hole,
it certainly is a very complex molecule,
but it can't do anything by itself.
This is where viruses make
everything more complicated.
They are basically strings of RNA or
DNA in a small hall and need cells to do
something.
We're not sure if they count as living
or dead and still there are 225 million
cubic meters of viruses on earth. They
don't seem to care what we think of them.
There are even viruses that invade dead
cells and reanimate them so they can be
a host for them,
which blurs the line even more.
Or they are the power plants of most
complex cells and were previously free
living bacteria that entered a
partnership with a bigger cells.
They still have their own DNA
and can multiply on their own,
but they are not alive anymore.
They are dead.
So they traded their own life
for the survival of their DNA,
which means living things can evolve into
dead things as long as it's beneficial
to their genetic code.
So maybe knife is information that
manages to ensure its continued existence.
But what about AI?
Artificial intelligence by
almost common definitions,
we are very close to creating
artificial life in computers.
It's just a question of time before
the technology we built gets that.
And this is not science fiction either.
There are a lot of smart people
actively working on this.
You could already argue the computer
viruses are alive. Hmm. Okay,
so what is life then? Things, processes,
DNA information.
This got confusing very fast.
One thing is for sure the idea that
knife is fundamentally different from
nonliving things because they contain
some nonphysical animate or are governed
by different principles than inanimate
objects. Turns out to be wrong.
Before Charles Darwin humans draw a
line between themselves and the rest of
living things. There was something
magical about us that made us special.
Once we had to accept, we are like every
living being a product of evolution.
We drew a different vibe,
but the more we learn about what
computers can do and how life works,
the closer we get to creating the first
machine that fits our description of
life, the more our image of
ourselves is in danger again,
and this will happen sooner or later.
And here's another question for you.
If everything in the universe
is made of the same staff,
does this mean everything in the universe
is dead or that everything in the
universe is alive?
That it's just a question of complexity.
Does this mean we can never die?
Because we were never alive in the first
place is life and death and a relevant
question and we haven't noticed it yet.
Is it possible we are much more part of
the universe around us than we thought?
Don't look at us.
We don't have any answers for you.
Just questions for you to think about.
After all,
it's thinking about questions like this
that makes us feel alive and gives us
some comfort.